Jennifer is with us in Denver hi
Jennifer how are you I'm good thank you
for taking my call
sure what's up um I was wondering when
people get married what do they do with
their finances how do they just suddenly
combine everything yes baby shouldn't
like split everything right down the
middle
no you combine everything there's no
middle the preacher didn't say and now
you're a joint-venture he said and now
you're one so what if one person makes
more than the other like you're not a
partnership you're a marriage there is
no let me give you an example okay okay
my wife has not had an earned income for
30 years she stayed home with our
children I do not have an income we have
an income it's as much hers as it is
mine spiritually morally and by the way
legally okay and so it's it's our income
and she and I sit down were she to earn
an income it would be in the pot put on
a pile with mine and I don't get more
votes if I make more money mm-hmm we
both have a vote we both are going to
sit down together we love each other we
are going to decide about our you're
hearing my pronouns here we our not
yours mine it's not my car your car now
we do say that's her car because she
drives that car most the time but she's
more than welcome to drive any car we
have I'm more than welcome to drive any
car we have it's not it's not entitled
exclusively to her name or to my name
it's ours we own everything the only
thing that is not ours is if the dog
poops on the floor that's my dog but
other than that we share it and see if
you change your language like that what
it forces you to do is it forces you to
set goals together instead of having
independent goals marriages are always
growing together or they're growing
apart
you can never stay status quo and so
when you set a goal together and you say
hey we
want to go on vacation and do X we want
to go to Italy and ride in a gondola and
eat pasta and drink Italian wine we want
to do that we want to save a million
dollars so we can give money and help
hungry children we want to pay off our
home we set goals together and then when
we are throwing everything at that we
have at our goals when we're sharing our
goals were sharing our lives does that
make sense it does yes and so it's not
it's not a when you separate them it's
as if your have a roommate instead of a
husband or a wife and spiritually
relationally even mathematically because
you know we tend the money tends to be
it creates all these weird conversations
when you do that that that are positive
for your relationship that otherwise
won't be created and so we don't go we
don't I don't go do a bunch of stuff
with money without talking to Sharon she
doesn't go do a bunch of stuff without
me and it's not that I'm not independent
or that she's not an independent woman
and able to make good decisions as a
strong woman believe me I'm married to a
strong woman but um it's not you know
but but it's none of that
it's that out of respect and love I am
very concerned and she's very concerned
that we're on the same page and we're
pulling together and so it's it's not me
thumping her or her thumping me and I'm
a weak guy or or she's a one of these
women that just does whatever her
husband says or something like that
which I don't have one of those I can
tell you that it's so you know we work
together I mean and sometimes we argue
about stuff but that argument causes us
to combine our future and our values
even makes us even discuss our fears
if you hurt our if you hurt our last
call with other last a couple here that
did the debt free scream they were at a
marriage conference and that he brought
up his greatest fear was he was not
going to be able to take care of his
family and she joined him in conquering
that fear by getting out of debt you
hear how that kind of worked in that
last call I did yeah that's what all
that's about is that logical to you it's
logical to me but my husband is
resistant so
like us oh I see okay how I can get him
on board well here's the thing
either he's wanting to be controlling or
um he's not doesn't trust your judgement
or um it could be any of those things or
it could be a lot of different things
but that's that's two things that come
up often when I'm doing coaching couples
and here's the thing I would say hey you
know number one calls a divorce and if
this was me you could say this to him
now I've been reading this stuff that
number one calls a divorce in North
America today is money fights and money
problems and couples there's a high
correlation with couples that are
married that build wealth and couples
that work together couples that don't
work together don't have nearly as high
a statistical probability of becoming
wealthy and I would love for us to work
together and I know it would be I know
there'll be some rough edges on it but
let's try it honey let's try let's try
combining everything and working
together if it doesn't work we could
take it back all apart but let's try
really really hard to pour into each
other going forward and you can even
play this call back for him if you want
it's on the internet now officially and
so you can listen to the podcast bring
the call up and you know play it back
out because you know it's not unusual
for people to separate things but
whatever is causing the separation if
it's a negative thing that is an
indication you need to work on that and
that's an opportunity to grow in your
relationship too so it's pretty cool
stuff hey you guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show and did you know that I have my
very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of better
Dave Ramsey Channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you